rule number one of multiversal travel
you don't know anything
so there's been a newly released doctor
strange in a multiverse of madness tv
spot trailer and we're going to break it
down so the trailer begins with doctor
strange asking america chavez to prove
that she can travel the multiverse which
then we cut to a shot of america chavez
created a star-shaped portal which then
our heroes doctor strange and america
chavez which i assume are transported
through different realities different
multiverses in one reality here it looks
like we can see a living tribunal and
before heroes come out of the starship
port on land we see them go through this
ice cave dimension the visuals here
looking very very good we then see
yamaka travis talking to doctor strange
which who says rule number one of
multiverse travel you don't know
anything we then cut to a shot where we
see the furnace range protecting america
chavez by casting a spell of some kind
some type of attack as america chavez
jumps into the distance i believe this
sequence is from the start of the film
where they are chased by this ribbon
looking creature we then have more
dialogue where doctor strange asks
america chavez what is rule number two
before cut into a different scene where
america chavez says look out and we see
a new shot of doctor strange fighting
gagantos before the trailer ends off
with one last interaction between the
two which i'll show you now market
anyway that pretty much sums up
everything for this breakdown so let me
know what you think of this new footage
and dialogue in the comment section
below if you haven't already please like
and subscribe to show your support